welcome to London we're from Canada we
can handle it
Mina don't die on your first day in
London okay
[Music]
[Music]
we got off the plane had to do me now
how'd you see
it's not bad Nina's seat wasn't working
properly didn't go down but they fix it
they had to do it manually but but you
still were able to sleep then he had a
medical emergency on the plane
therefore doctorate
anyway we got off we're gonna go through
customs and then head on the to London
is a tube I don't think I slept I rested
like I slept at all I rested welcome to
London
[Music]
how's that London air Nina
feels good actually a little chilly but
we're from Canada we can handle it
[Music]
ceilings low well you're pretty low
thinking of me and hit my head it does
look like I'm gonna get my hand it's
okay it's just big enough
England can't handle heaven I like the
music they play was a guy here that's
fine you want to chuck that McFlurry are
you already thinking about booty man
different food in London you want to go
to McDonald's that's what I used to
always do any time which is you City go
to McDonald's
how's the weather feel refreshing huh
alright alright time to explore some
London
so we officially know what we're going
Nina's our tour guide I'm the tour guide
we're gonna hit we're gonna go find our
hotel which is just past Trafalgar
Square which is one of the most popular
areas in London dump up our bags change
a little bit on the smelly side perhaps
you look both of us I think I need that
food look
and today's gonna be our exploring and
shopping and vibrant area City day once
we drop our stuff off let's go
the iconic British telephone booths I
wonder how much longer they're gonna be
around guys spot the Canada flag can you
see the can of the flag here's a clue
look at that
Canadian embassy straight ahead we're
not going there we're gonna hit our
hotel Nina's discovered some food what
do you want to eat you want to eat all
at the end remember we're going on a
cruise ship you're gonna have tons of
food on the cruise ship
[Music]
all right we made it in we got out in
pack we got to get rid of this heavy bag
ah ah yeah good lady I've been carrying
lots of stuff it's only home for one day
we leave tomorrow for the cruise we got
to make the most of today get changed
and hustle mean that you ready oh okay
good that's just gonna leave me hangin
she always left me hanging
I love you Nina you guys know when I
travel you know when I travel I need to
find CNN where CNN ah Nina we're
officially on vacation seeing Amazon all
right guys it's official it's officially
on cuz I got the shirt cuz we got the
shirt how you feelin Nina Nina wants to
hug it out oh how good Nina
time to go explore Nina want some food I
want some food I want a coffee actually
but ya wanna come I want a coffee and
some food it's time to explore we're
finally here Nina's in a new country and
we are excited we're here at Trafalgar
Square behind us some demonstrations
so the Iranian protest is behind us and
now there's a vegetarian protest in
front of us
this is the place to have a prototype
we didn't you know we didn't make their
way across before the boys started we
didn't make our way across what we want
to do is get to that there's a coffee
shop on the other side I don't know
we're gonna get through this I'm gonna
go through
Nina lead the way
Nina Nina don't die on your first day in
London okay Nina's a celebrity she's
recognized here all right our
destination let's get some coffee
all right you like this job so that was
the first time Nina God stop is that the
first time you've been stopped
yeah I ain't got stopped before me so
Nina's kicking up her celebrity profile
here in London
look out friends Nina's on the warpath I
got a I got to be your bodyguard
yeah
all right exploration continues the
chaos is pretty much over behind this
the vegan festival March and now we're
gonna move on see we can find so this is
the Iranian gathering it's a lot more
peaceful than the beeping lot less
yelling they're just watching a message
I don't know what they're saying about
that so this is the place to come to
make a statement I feel like we need an
entrepreneur alley next to fogger square
I'm not winner stand up
[Music]
oh that's Shakespeare William
Shakespeare did you read Shakespeare in
school your memorized everything need to
be or not to be that is a question
if picking facedown animatic please
brother selfie
[Music]
we love you Nina Nina
[Music]
you know this Chinatown every big city
has a Chinatown you're curious you want
to go Nina wants to go okay here we go
let's hit the Chinatown what's special
about the golden Phoenix
[Music]
a missing kid dream that's what we're on
no sister
yeah a lot of the streets would be
similar names Yonge Street Yonge Street
I don't know actually
King Street Queens
[Applause]
Chinese
[Applause]
[Music]
we're stopping to get some food Nina's
hungry
this sandwich RI Nina is starving so
she's not have been waiting you kind of
got angry but here we go how is it Nina
we should leave me alone for a few
minutes let her intrude get some food in
her that's cool we're going in the foils
bookstore I'm gonna see if they have my
book me is there the inside so oils is
the most iconic bookstore in London it's
been around for over 100 years they have
six different stories of books and gifts
and a lot of the North American stores
then mega bookstores are modeled after
this store here so I'm excited to see if
they carry my book well good news bad
news they're sold out so I guess that's
a good thing but I wanted to see it in
the store so thank you to the London
believe nation folk who supported the
book and
it's old foils out and foils let's get
going on a reorder I want to come and
sign some books and take some pictures
and put it in the vlog next time all
right you cannot continue on with the
day
[Music]
we are hunting for one of the most
famous fish and chips places in London
Nina one at local food London has a lot
of international restaurants but she
didn't want to have Indonesian or Indian
or Japanese stuff she wanted something
London so fish and chips that's what
we're doing and we're off to find one of
the most famous houses in London if we
can find it but there's so many options
here there's so many different
restaurants there's so much potential
Nina wants to eat everywhere save it for
the fish and chips we found it the rock
and soul place mmm smell it Nina you
smell it smell the fish and chips all
right we're gonna go get our food on
here's the menu
look rock and soul place spelt weird
original fish and chips
eirick I saw the fish authentic fish a
lot mushy peas look at that hot mushy
peas
we only fry in the highest-quality
groundnut oil
what's groundnut oil Nina Nina she's
lost in the menu okay we're starting up
with some FS draught beer from Turkey
just the London one the ad was super
dark well try doing with one hand okay
thank you
oh it's good I like it we're starting
with the starter we got what is that
calamari and jumbo shrimp and there's a
third thing spring with Taiwan just dip
it in bite
it's okay all right and this is what we
came for the fish and chips we've got
some Cod some chips tartar sauce dill
sauce tartar sauce I guess my mouth is
watering
let's call the chip it's a chip good
ketchup on my chips but okay it's Cod
time this is that moment of truth why we
came here
yeah look at that white meat in there
okay there it goes and in it goes
and it's hot whoo it's hot
yes Jesse nice all right high five good
place
boom so they've been doing this since
1871
how you doing Nina
both Nina's very fault
ready to sleep she's chilling back on
the bench
she left me all the fries to eat but
she's gonna finish your beer the pigeon
keeps stylus he likes you like Nina feed
me food you know feed me food the pigeon
alright I'm still finishing the fries
but dessert came sticky toffee with ice
cream and caramel sauce the Nina's going
to give it a shot come on Nina
yeah am I gonna have any left when I
finish my fries okay we're done eating I
am so full that brownie thing was
amazing the toffee pudding whatever yes
and then the beer and the fries it was
good I'm feeling full well we're gonna
walk back to the hotel and I feel like I
need a good walk gotta walk it off gotta
walk it off not used to eating this much
food sean has this on this you know we
have a strict strict diet which did not
include any of this food
none of this food included so it feels
good and it feels terrible at the same
time but our stomachs I think I'm gonna
stretch at the end of this so we're
gonna find our way back to the hotel
here we go Nina misses Timo
universe' scheme however every die she's
seen every changes look at that smile
here there's a smile look at the big
penis smile you misty Muffy it's only
been one day you know has he even been
24 hours that's okay
it's Meena love it's all Nina love we
decided to buy some snacks
just in case we got hungry even though
our faces are full our stomachs are
insanely crunch we decided that we need
some snacks just in case so we bought
candy kittens wild strawberry while sour
watermelon gourmet candies some Pringles
sour cream and onion and she's an onion
and then - what is that spicy lobster
noodles and
chicken abalone I don't like the chicken
apples all right
so tomorrow we got on the cruise ship so
we got to eat all this before tomorrow
what do you think maybe what we don't
have Forks we're pretty mile J all right
go get some ports all right so it is the
end of day one
officially for us this is day zero thank
you guys for joining us the Sun is
setting on London we waited we made it
jet lag is decent we're gonna go to the
hotel shower clean up maybe have some
noodles watch some H as a shield go to
bed and get ready to wake up before the
cruise you got stopped
you got stopped on the street and say
hey Nina you're a celebrity you need to
get Nina Nina Carmichael shirts now just
guys if watching if you ever have seen
Nina on the street make sure you say hi
because we flew here to London and the
highlight was that somebody stopped her
on the street
so feel like we make that happen in
multiple places that just Romina thank
you guys for watching have an amazing
weekend
p'tee to believe in whatever your one
word is much love see you soon